We're so far away from where
we were in the 70s so far away,
so far away, so far away.
And that was our lifetime.
We can remember the 70s you know,
1973 I was six years old. Okay.
I remember that. I remember,
I remember the Vietnam War.
I remember when the war ended
thinking when I was a little kid.
This is great that the war's over because
now they know that war is bad and they
won't do any war anymore.
The war is over, it's gone.
And then when the war started up again,
when I was,
I think I was 21 when Desert Storm
kicked in, I was at Holy Shit,
they're doing it again.
Me and my friend Jimmy did
tell you we had an apartment in
think it was fucking where,
where we Malden or some shit,
I forget where the fuck we were.
Wall Fan. That's where we are,
where we are in Walt Dam.
We had this fucking apartment and uh,
we were sitting there on TV, which is
sitting in front of the delivery room.
I didn't think we had a couch.
We just sitting there and the living room
watching these fucking missiles flying
through the air and I'll never forget.
He goes, buddy looks like we're at war.
And I was like, what? How the UF,
we're both sitting there going, what?
How the fuck we're at war?
I thought we didn't do that anymore.
I remember that.
I remember that whole,
that time when,
when that was how you got information
from the TV is so far removed from today.
Today,
everything that happens all the time
is coming at Ya a hundred miles an hour
from every direction.
There's just too much.
You have to control it.
You still have to have a
life. You still, you know,
I don't have Facebook on my phone.
I have my email account.
I try to keep Twitter off my
phone when I go on the road.
The IPAD has no Twitter,
no Facebook. It's too much.
It's too much.
It interferes with who we are.
And if you haven't caught that by now,
you're not catching this. You know,
I helped open up my Twitter on a
Saturday just to see who's tweeting,
thinking to myself,
what are you doing with your fucking
life that you're tweeting on Friday and
fucking Saturday and Sunday.
You know,
it becomes a little game.
It's, it's a little game. You
have to give it a breather.
You have to you,
it's too much news coming at you from
too old too on your satellite disk.
It's in. Oh, other thing is it's too
much news from sports to World News.
You got Hln,
CNN and then ESPN all of the fucking row.
It's too fast. It's too quick.
Last week when I was home,
my buddy is a cab driver.
I took six.
Uber's on Monday in New York.
Tuesday I just wanted to take a cab.
I took my wife to get some real pizza.
Roma Pizza.
The guy that was making pizza
that was there when I was a kid.
I drove by one day and I go,
he still in there.
So we took a fucking cab on the cat and
this guy that drove me as a friend of
mine, we grew up together since we
were 12 and we would talk and I go,
that's a fair ask first gas station that
robbed and then he got some memorable,
we were 12 we were walking home the
night Freddy Prince got killed. Wow.
Freddie prince who killed
himself than they before.
We didn't find out till about six o'clock
news. Do you know what I'm saying?
Like that was the gap in time.
So you got your news and the,
even though that was New York,
it was the city capitol who
watch TV in the morning.
Maybe they mentioned it in the morning
reports out of La Friday Prinze is in the
hospital. Yeah, but you never
saw it. But no, I still,
I remember us being out and
them saying Freddy Prince died.
He shot himself last night and
I started my, how cold it was.
It was January or February.
It was fucking freezing,
but we were walking home. We were 12
and what do we see in front of us?
But a guy passed out drunk,
just haven't drunk on the floor.
So when I call down,
let's get the money out of his pocket.
You take the bottle,
it was like a bottle
of Dewar's or whatever.
So I plan was to take a bottle and
shake a bum. What? What's it called?
You roll a bum? Yeah, we
put our hands in his pocket.
He grabbed one of us like Carrie.
So next thing you know,
all three of us just started kicking him
like we must have kicked the maybe two
times
and we ran away the bottle.
He got up and chases. Oh Jesus. We knew
as sharp path through the cemetery.
So we lost them.
Like you get all those weird things
like that's what I associate with like
Freddy shot himself at night.
They must've mentioned it in the morning.
I was too busy going to school and
it wasn't confirmed to the next day.
That's how slow knew is was.
Now you're getting news,
you're getting hit with
200 stories in 10 minutes.
What happened in France?
What Trump decided what the UFC is doing,
what fucking Penny Marshall died.
You get this true natural all day, you
really can't control it. Take your child,
you've watched these
two young girls grow up.
You ever have days where
you take them somewhere,
Disney and it's so much information they
got to go back and take a nap. Yeah,
it happens to have step two
that's gotta be happening to us.
Well for sure it's wearing you out and
it's a lot of it is really negative too.
That's another part of the problem
is what's interesting to people's,
what's dangerous and
there's not much dangerous.
So what's interesting to people
becomes, you know, being negative,
being nasty about something, complaining
about things, bitching that, starting
starting Twitter fights. Like people
enjoy doing it. They were like,
they're looking for,
for battles, you know?
And I wish there was a way where people
could choose to only engage online
without insulting people and just
try and get a rise out of people,
like a troll free way of interacting.
But it's never going to happen.
So you've got to kind of accept what
it is, is if you accept what it is,
you should be very wary about entering
to anything where 60% of what you're
experiencing is negative.
Anything,
anything in life where you're looking
at 60% negative, you don't have to.
It is the one you like.
Being informed is one thing,
but that's more than just being informed.
Cause how much of that information
is even valuable to you.
A lot of it is just getting soaked, soaked
into these fucking horrible stories.